says we're live so don't live okay and
we are live well hello everyone and
welcome to round table with the stream
team and this is where we speak to
content creators about their journey of
becoming a content creator and what
they've you know what they've built in
their empire so today we have the
saltiest gamer here or salty gaming as
everyone probably knows him on the
interwebs or every five minutes he
changes his Twitter handle how are you
my man it's funny man yeah you're not
the first person to say that it Twitter
is one of those places for me that I
like to like stretch my legs creatively
so sometimes I'll I'll throw some
different pictures there for my Twitter
avatar and then change the name and
change it up you never know what you're
gonna get I you know what lots of memes
lots of gifts yeah I'm happy that you
were able to come to come here I know
that we you and I when we had a little
back-and-forth with me trying to come up
to your podcast I'm happy that I was
able to do it I said I had to I had to
get you on so oh yeah thank you thank
you for joining us today
now we have two other of the stream team
members here today we have MJ's Abbas he
is back from college or still in the
middle of college he's still in the
middle syllable how much longer you got
one two weeks two weeks you count down
the minutes
no I be kidding around I'd want them
over into the finals
oh then your finals oh no I have a week
and then it's finals week
okay well two weeks and then you get to
go home and then you get to you know
sleep until whatever and you're good to
go so you know you get to finally catch
up with some games like destiny inky
things like that so yeah I'm happy you
were able to finally make it back you
know back great great great and we have
l-boogie
how's everybody doing tonight we're good
we're good how are you doing I'm pretty
good pretty good
that's hit in the face this morning when
I had to go to work you know that's a
long week is it a fantastic you know
nice four day weekend yeah I was like
kind of like five days everybody was
basically already out of the office on
Wednesday so I just work from home oh
nice I I always take off the three days
before Thanksgiving so I know that's the
worst I was like work so but it was that
at least you didn't have to get another
being ready oh yes thankfully I don't
have to do that oh hello clever gaming
and welcome good sir thank you for the
low so so while we are all here we are
here to speak to the saltiest gaming how
are you what's going on and tell us why
you wanted to become any content creator
okay where do where do I start man start
slowly start from the beginning like why
why you decided to do so are you guys
getting some feedback
yeah it's me hold on okay all right so
what was the question again so start
from the beginning like why like why did
you become a content creator why did you
like what kind of prompted you to want
to do it okay yeah all right so my wife
actually started doing stuff with my my
daughter they did this thing called
Kenzi adventures my daughter has autism
and stuff like that so they went out and
did some like video recording she
started doing YouTube she's like hey you
know how come you know you don't do
YouTube you're like always talking about
gaming and this and that I don't
understand anything you're saying cuz
she's not really that big at the gaming
ring yeah so I was like yeah you know I
don't know man it's it takes all this
and that and I didn't even know where to
begin
you know so but she's like yeah just do
it so I put it off for the longest time
you know like year
and then all of a sudden you know I had
a piece of crap laptop and I didn't even
start on the laptop actually I did a
upload studio on xbox if you guys are
familiar with that piece of crap um
started doing videos on there you know
it was around III 2017 right before it
did a video and then I did a podcast
with my buddies it was called dads of
gaming podcast I think we had like one
person maybe in there we did it like
midnight on Arizona time or somebody -
we didn't we didn't know what we were
doing and then it just went from there
man I just didn't know what I was doing
like everybody else on YouTube and it
just kind of grew into what it is now
but it's been lots of work but it's
stuff that I I didn't imagine myself
doing but it's stuff that I love I love
gaming I love talking about gaming in
all things like that and the ability to
meet people across the world you you
know they share your same passions
amazing for me so that's why I do it is
to the community aspect and getting to
know people and stuff like that and
sharing my passion with others so so
like you think you've been doing this
for how long how long have you been
working in 2007 2017 summer June I think
something like that mr. Joo soju soju is
when you started that that dad podcasts
really yeah yeah yeah and the editing
and stuff like that you ended up doing
on your own ourselves like straight
conversation or someone else took care
of it all right so the podcast has never
been edited it's just Google Hangouts
like we're doing yeah
with videos I did upload studios and it
was no editing whatsoever it was me
getting on the mic I would literally sat
down on my couch had you know the upload
studio was crap dude like honestly like
I don't even know how I did it because
it was it had a bunch of glitches and
sometimes I'd lose my work that I put
effort into but it was straight one take
you know I said um and Mike and then you
know it just wasn't that professional
but I guess you know people still
watched it or whatever for whatever
reason and then it just went from there
to make improvements right I went and
switched to my my laptop which was a
piece of crap and it barely and then I
had Premiere Elements and it it glitched
out all the time and then it's just
small improvements like I got a better
mic and then you know I try to do this
than that try to edit my videos and try
to make better quality videos cuz it's
always a process on YouTube you can't
stay stagnant you got to find the areas
you're weak and then keep improving
social media is a big part of what I do
when I started my Twitter I made it a
point to be active in the community so
in other people's chats and you know on
social media following people making
friends there and stuff cuz it's it's
difficult on YouTube to get noticed in
YouTube gaming especially because
there's millions of people doing the
same things you know so yeah it's the
whole content creator realm if you will
it's almost like you are literally a
drop of water in an ocean oh yeah the
disc and what what I always like to call
it it's like being in the lotto and then
not winning it but winning it twice cuz
like you almost have to win for people
to find you and then win again to be so
popular to you know survive on it so
it's almost like you have to almost like
go through it twice yeah with content
creation people don't understand how
difficult it is because people think
well once you get successful videos or
you get subscribers then you're set
right now that's not really how it works
because Google is always changing the
algorithms and if you don't stay
up-to-date on how it works how the
changes are you'll get left behind you
stop getting views you stop getting this
and that and that's that's the big thing
because people are always saying you
know how do I get views on YouTube mmm
well it's not it's not an exact science
because trust me I've watched all the
videos
you know all the videos on how to
improve your thumbnails and your in your
your your titles and your descriptions
and your keywords I mean it's uh I think
it's like flipping a coin half the time
with the algorithm with YouTube you know
so yeah well it's it's important when
you're starting off to interact with
people on social media in my opinion
because YouTube's the social media
platform it's run by Google Twitter is
the big social media platform but in
order to stand out and you said in that
ocean you gotta you gotta make friends I
don't know you gotta start talking to
people or get in the chat and you know
try to do it that way I guess right do
you feel do you feel like social media
and networking is more important than
your content that you produce in the
beginning I would say it is because
realistically in this environment of
YouTube to stand out without doing
social media I think it's almost nearly
impossible because it's just it's tough
you know it's kind of like applying for
a job and they ask you for work
experience and you don't have that work
experience right because you just got
out of college you're like well how am I
supposed to get it work experience in
this field that I'm trying to get a job
in it's kind of a catch-22
that's the thing with YouTube because
you're trying to get in the algorithm
you're trying to get views without
subscribers when you're first starting
off so how do you get subscribers if you
don't have the views etc etc it's it
goes around in circles but if you can be
on social media and kind of get your
presence out there the maybe if you put
a post on Twitter or Facebook maybe
you'll get some people to come back
start watching your videos subscribing
and stuff like that that's just my
opinion some people might not have that
viewpoint on it but I think that social
media is very important you know the the
podcasts that I was on you know the
saltiest gaming podcast do you push that
out just to youtube or do you push it
out to other platforms also alright so
I've been asked this a lot for the
podcast so you
at this moment I do not put it on other
platforms and there's reasons for that
when you tell people that you're on
other podcast arenas that's cool if
you're trying to get people to go to
those things but anytime you link off
platform so off YouTube you're pulling
your audience out of watching your
videos on YouTube you know so if I'm
telling people I'm other on other
platforms they'll go and watch it there
and still watching on YouTube and
YouTube what I'm trying to build up
right now so that's why I don't do it at
this point I mean if I get bigger and
bigger where I can it's I'm okay with
the push you got to pay for you know all
this other stuff like hosting it and all
that other stuff maybe down the line I
will do that but at this moment I've
talked to some people that have been
doing it and they just they didn't
recommend it you know so ya know the you
only have the one podcast correct yeah
at this moment cuz it's just before I
did multiple ones I did one with boom I
did what was it gaming news at noon I
did that I've done I've done multiple
shows I've done live reactions and stuff
but right now we're at one so Thursdays
at 8:00 yeah do you do you feel like
that's that's more than enough for your
channel to grow because I see it
consistently having growth which is
always like a pop yeah yeah
yeah so the interesting I've had this
discussion with Rand and some other
people in on YouTube so the way YouTube
works is it has algorithms right it you
do certain things on your channel and
it's supposed to track you and and rank
you and search for what you do so if you
have live streams on your channel then
it puts you in a certain category if you
do traditional videos than it's gonna
track you for certain things like if I
do Nintendo it will probably try to put
me into Nintendo people that watch
Nintendo products or content if I do
live streams that'll try to push you
towards those people that watch that
content so it's you're not growth
through
traditional podcast only like on YouTube
it's kind of tough because if you look
at podcasts that are 2 hours long
generally they get about the same views
they average about the same views you're
not gonna pull in a lot of subscribers
just doing podcasts because that's not
the way YouTube works they like to push
out videos that are within a certain
length I think max length is like 25
minutes to be able to attract in the
algorithm so typically you're not gonna
have podcast track for algorithm at all
very little you know so if you're trying
to get more subs it's not the best way
to do that by just doing live streams if
that makes sense
because you can still get views but to
get new stuff like subs brand new people
that have never watched your content it
is traditionally harder to build that
way yeah if that makes sense
yeah yeah because there's like there's
big people out there like Joe Rogan
right he's getting millions of views on
his podcasts you know so it's different
that that way so that's at least from
what I've talked to on people on the
outside right you look at your analytics
because they have a really good in the
analytics section it breaks it down like
how many people are watching your video
the how many like the reach right they
they put your content out to a certain
amount of new people the click-through
rate how many people are clicking on
your thumbnails how many new subscribers
you get from those videos you could you
can break down everything so you can see
how many subscribers you're getting per
video or per podcast it's right there in
front of you because YouTube tracks
everything you know oh yeah well that's
that's the thing that like we we hear of
kind of have noticed that it's it's
turned into you know having to check for
the analytics you have to check for your
content you know check their keywords
it's yes it seems like there's a million
different variables to allow you to do
more noticed and
that's the one thing that we another guy
myself
and the other guys they end up saying is
that they want to they want to make sure
to be seen that's why we go we go to a
lot of different conventions and things
like that because we like to be able to
communicate and like I always walk with
my business cards now and just as
weekend I was just walking in Trader
Joe's and some dudes so I mean with my
twitch Odion
and it was like hey you play twitch I'm
like yeah I do I have a podcast and this
is the yeah this is another podcast not
you handle my business cards and it's
come to the point now where I'm just in
the I just I have a habit of that and
what about like like going to
conventions like that we go to
conventions and we are always talking to
people and doing that do you think you
think that that is a helpful way for
your for your growth for your channel
it's definitely something that I need to
do I was trying to get to e3 last year
but then I had my baby just my baby's
born in July and they had III in June so
I was planning on going but things came
up but this year I'm planning on going
III packs all those things I think are
very very very useful for content
creators because you make connections
and that's what we've been talking about
right connection the building
friendships and all kinds of different
things right so if you're in a
convention like that you have a chance
of meeting with people that you could
bring on potentially for interviews or
the sky's the limit and I think that
getting your name out there to gamers
that are there like those are the
hardest core gamers you could find right
right because those they're at those
conventions so I think that yeah like
passing your your cards around doing
giveaways there and doing some other
stuff to give you get your name out I
think that's an extremely very very good
way to do it you know if you have the
resources to get to those events yeah I
just haven't done yet yeah uh-huh
has how was having your child like
changed your kids I should say in your
family how was it changed your whole
outlook of gaming and being able to
continue to make content
it's changed my outlook a lot because I
was doing this originally with one kid
and it just kind of threw my whole
content creation off the tilt of access
like very demoralizing to be honest
because I love having a baby but having
a newborn baby it just changes
everything schedules all kinds of other
stuff going on I actually had to leave
gaming news at noon because schedules
were changing and in life changes and
it's not just my baby it's just
everything right we have our life's
going on everything that we have our
personal lives and stuff so it's tough
to stay consistent with content creation
streaming on Twitch or making videos or
doing any of that stuff because you have
to remain consistent to be able to have
your subscribers stick around or your
viewers want to like build a community
with you and that's very very difficult
if you have a kid and you have a wife or
you have a husband or you have a partner
because it does take time away right you
have to have someone that's
understanding of that and it's like cool
with what you do or it could cause
friction there luckily my wife's cool
she supports me and stuff like that but
it is it is tough right cuz you got out
like squeeze in time like today when I
made my video I was surprised I even got
it out because I had to get my kid ready
for school I was like drinking my coffee
and my if we're feeding the baby and I
was doing audio recordings in between
the spare moments that I had you know
and then push the video out and you know
some people don't have any of that right
they don't have kids or significant
other and they can make a video on the
fly when the news comes out and that
kind of super advantageous right to get
pushed but you got to do what you got to
do right with what you have yeah exactly
exactly l do you do you agree with you
agree with what salty saying for sure
like even when I was about to start like
my mom thinks this is like such
dorkiness
so she's always like cracking jokes and
stuff but she's gotten better it's like
from when I first started for sure as
before she would like plan stuff when I
told her I'd be busy doing this type of
and now it's just like easier my kids
she loves us she'd probably be in here
talking with you guys if I let her yeah
it's it's always juggling you know when
you have a family yeah definitely
definitely MJ how is it how's it been
for you with the whole changing with you
know with school because you know I know
that you've been kind of crazy busy with
stuff too
yeah you like the whole your haunts well
you can even consider you all your
fraternity brothers you know family if
you will so like once once you started
doing that process like you were you
were m.i.a for weeks and like you know
for for you and I like I know that we
usually text like every couple of days
and like I I think I texted you or spoke
to you maybe twice in three or four
weeks and I was like alright as long as
he's breathing and not like you know
half dead and a quarter drunk at the
fraternity house you know we're good so
so so just something to kind of come
come back salty now you I noticed that
you started streaming on Twitch correct
so why why was there that decision to go
on to twitch instead of mixer or or why
why was it that that was the platform
that you decided on alright so it was a
big decision for me because originally
when I started streaming i was doing
youtube but then youtube's just not a
viable platform to stream games they
they cut all right so youtube was trying
to compete with twitch with youtube
gaming they had this whole side
application that no one used and they
just can that that project got canned
they de monetize people regularly like
if you have music for in the game it's
just any kind of music you'll get your
stream demonetized right
the whole the whole stream will get D
monetize like I'll be streaming for like
four hours or three hours and look at
the the stream as the monitor
I'm like man this is like I'm tired of
this you know like putting time and
effort into it and then just it's just
not worth it so I decided hey I need to
take my game streaming specifically off
platform to one of these other two I
looked in the mixer honestly it was a it
was I was thinking maybe but I had my
playstation and I don't have this set up
right now with OBS or all that other
fancy stuff right now so I had to stream
directly from the PlayStation and that
doesn't go to mixer you know so I want
if I wanted to stream you know both
systems twitch was the only place they
could do it so that that's why I decided
to go with them plus their affiliate
program I like that I like the idea of
like what it took to get into that and
they're actually improving on that and I
think they're thinking about giving
affiliates the ability to game revenue
off of ads I got an email but yeah so I
know that like I myself I stream on
Twitch Monday to Friday
I know L when she's on she's on mixer
usually Monday through Friday or Monday
a Thursday or something like that and MJ
I know it is on on Twitch also so the
whole process for the for the ad revenue
on the ads it's you roll enough ads to
pretty much produce money but you have
to do it like it's like almost every
half hour or every hour you have to roll
an ad like a like a two-minute ad and
you have to do for a while you can do it
yourself you also every single time you
have a person come into your channel who
is not a sub they get an ad so okay the
more which kind of it worse that your
benefit so if you're a larger streamer
alright and as I like to call it there's
an old newspaper term called above the
fold if you're high enough on that list
of streamers that you have a huge amount
of people coming into your channel that
will team reach the amount of number you
need to produce to produce revenue after
you break that threshold excuse me if
you break that threshold
you start making more money off of it
okay yeah I so the thing with twitch
like I like a lot of the things that
they're doing right
I like the affiliate program I like how
they send you emails about your average
viewers new you know new people coming
in subscribers all that other stuff it's
accessible I feel like they're listening
about the smaller term you know smaller
time channels trying to get noticed and
stuff because they've changed the layout
with twitch I don't know if you guys
notice this but you can make us where
like when you're searching for games you
can make it like where it's like
randomize it's not like from high to low
it'd be like recommended and stuff like
that I didn't know that was on and I was
like scrolling through the games list
and I was like well why is someone with
like 15 people watching at the top of
the list for one of these popular games
and it's just the way it's sent out
there and the fact that affiliates can
actually get ad revenue or subscribers
is cool there's the twitch prime thing
so people are more willing to do that
plus the bits they can donate bits it is
pretty ridiculous the requirements for
partner though so there's there's a
couple of there's a couple of inside
information from from what from what
I've conversed with partners about but
the the when you get to partner you
don't actually need to produce that
threshold it depends upon your gaming
percentage I know people that do not
have 75 viewers in their channel you
know to produce that average to get that
path to partner status if you will and
they got partnered it's based pretty
much on the channel itself and what
you're consistently streaming these
people were consistently streaming
sports games so during that sports game
it was kind of on the lesser end so it
was kind of like he was able to get in I
do know that some people who are people
like are there streaming games like
World of Warcraft which has a huge
following people have hundreds of
viewers today from that
it's kind of a little bit harder to end
up to getting to and to get through to
that but still you you only need that 75
threshold and then you you're good to go
you get that partner and you're good and
you're good but I mean I've I've been on
Twitch
maybe maybe four or five years I've only
really been going hardcore for it over
the past three and I was able to make
that affiliate threshold when they
announced it and if they've actually you
know really evolved it and made it a lot
better for instance now we can have more
than one emote for a Tier one sup which
is a big deal in my book because people
don't but they're not going to sub to
your channel for one emo or some people
they if they come to your channel they
love your emotes they'll just sub for
the emotes and put those you know people
that have like you know huge followings
but I really I personally enjoy what
what they're doing for that but L is
there something similar on mixer for
like that so now we have embers for all
for everyone so like I monetize on my
channel I'm able to monetize on my
channel what does it call it and I can't
remember how much it is what the
percentage of the embers is I know that
like on Twitch it's like there you're
the person is buying $15 and you're
getting $10 and twitch is getting $5 but
so I don't know how that breakdown is
for mixer but yeah I'm able to monetize
now they open it up for everybody but
like I'm not able to like clip stuff
like partners can clip stuff which I
hate I put something into my stream dick
but I haven't been playing around with
it I'm usually forget to do it so it's
kind of nice that on Twitch like anybody
can clip stuff for you anybody that's
viewing your channel can clip stuff for
you what's gonna say and I don't know if
they've rolled out the embers for all to
everyone yet or not but um hopefully
that's coming soon to allow everyone to
monetize no matter if their partner you
know just does mixer have the ability
like twitch has four
the app on your phone to be able to go
IRL walking around with the with your
phone so one of the things with twitch
they actually the app on the cell phone
you can actually go to your to your
twitch application on your phone and
then there's the thing let's just go
live and you can actually go straight go
live from your phone like if you want to
be like on the street and be like yo I'm
down here in the mall hanging out with
my homies and we're good so you know I
was just curious it was just one of
those things it's been a while to make
sure you did more what Apple okay which
whenever I say that people were like oh
they do this they do that
another great I'm so happy
but they're not even so unless they're
even been I still want you to do more
yeah yeah I agree I agree so going back
to salty with the with the streaming on
Twitch I I have been lurking in their
channel once in a blue moon I don't know
if you see me or not but I've seen you
play two games one which I which I will
get very excited about what the other
one was Uncharted did you never play the
Uncharted series before no I didn't man
so my history with things and crease him
and shout-out to him because he's salty
right now but the deal is this like I
got I got a PlayStation like four months
ago five months ago right and before
that I was an Xbox gamer and I had a
Nintendo and I've told people this like
I had Nintendo's Super Nintendo Nintendo
original 64 and then I got in the Xbox
ecosystem and I was pretty much set you
know I'm saying xbox original 360 Xbox
one Xbox one X and then I've been
wanting to play PlayStation games for a
while just never have done it and then
this generation the thing that it was
the tipping point was got a war I saw
that game I was like dude I got to get
that PlayStation with spider-man and all
those games I wanted to play them it's
just I didn't know if I had the time and
it's just extra money and all this other
stuff so yeah Uncharted it was up to
I you know isn't my favorite type of
game is Tomb Raider my favorite type of
game no but do I enjoy the the hell out
of it yeah but it is the first time I'm
experiencing the Uncharted series that
you can drink yeah I did I bought the
the Nathan Drake collection too I have
it I bought it for 10 bucks so nice nice
yeah because I I personally have never
played it I do not own any PlayStation I
know my brother played the the originals
on the ps3 and he loved them and he's
like you got to play him and I was like
let me borrow your PlayStation 3 and
he's like nothing will work cuz the
cd-rom doesn't work I was like I hate
you so so but unfortunately I'm so long
I'm hoping that with the PS 5 being
backwards compatible to pull out all my
old ps1 and ps2 games and play those
because I have the old Final Fantasy
Tactics in Fantasy 7 and all those
original discs perfect condition and my
boxes upstairs
and I want to play those but one of the
games that a lot of us here have played
fall in order how amazing is that for
you it's awesome and I streamed that
game I'm one of the biggest Star Wars
fans out there honestly I could talk
your ear off for four hours if we were
doing a podcast on on Star Wars I could
talk for as long as I needed to right
but that game has its issues right I
mean I feel like it was rushed out a
little bit like six months too early has
some bugs has some walk eNOS to it and
people are saying it's like a mixture of
Uncharted which it is man and I like
playing Uncharted now I'm like seeing
what you know that game had and what it
took from Uncharted like the sliding and
the remaining and the ropes and this and
that
that's fine I've talked to people about
that like entertainment you you pull
from all kinds of different things right
you get inspiration from great games and
Uncharted is a great game so I don't
blame respawn for doing that I feel like
they're like hey I love this game and I
love this game and I love this game cool
let's jam that all together and make a
conglomerate into one badass game like a
badass Tower
game and I think it's awesome we've
never had a Star Wars game that was like
Dark Souls where you have checkpoints
and the fighting feels so smooth I'm
actually you know using a lightsaber so
it's my game of the Year 2019 I know it
has issues but on the fun factor and the
story for me as a Star Wars fan there's
nothing that even comes close because
I'm kind of like starving for content as
a Star Wars fan I want to get more
content I want to hear more stories that
are in the kit the Canon so the ability
to go and see those things after order
66 is like a dream come true for me and
I sound like a fanboy I sound like one
of those kojima stands is playing no no
no you are not because I know that you
have I myself I'm a huge Star Wars fan
and I'm pretty sure you're a big star
Wars fan also because you used to live
yeah used to live in galaxies edge over
when you were living in California okay
have you finished have you suspenseful
or yet or now no I'm pretty close right
now my planet for the second time I'm
gonna ask one question and it's not a
spoiler to anything mmm did you go
through the arena yet oh yeah that took
me like it took me a couple of hours to
be a couple of hours when I been getting
frustrated no I did in two days so like
I didn't it for a couple of hours got
frustrated got off waited a couple of
days came back and I beat it
so you're still playing it on not the
top level not like master also and I
mean yeah I mean it my like my job to
make sure that I'm always dreaming when
I'm playing that game so one day last
week my wife passed out in bed and I was
streaming it and I literally started it
at 11 o'clock and I said to myself if I
go to bed without completing this I'm
we're gonna be able to complete this cuz
I'm just gonna lose my groove so I just
pushed and pushed and then I finally
finished it up around 1:30 and I was
like alright cool got it done
I don't have to worry about this anymore
no see I think it was nice that I like
came back refreshed because then it was
like I already knew what I needed to do
and then like it was easier to get into
the groove real quick and then it also
helped because I was streaming too and
shout-out to bloody knuckles cuz he came
through and he was like do the trick
with the spider which I totally forgot
even though I knew it from e3 which one
so if you block when the spiders put
their hands up mm-hmm right at the right
time then you get to do it it's the
insta kill on them at the end of the
arena when you got those two big
monsters yep if you get rid of the
spider quick then you're like good to go
and then I found out later that they
were like I should have had an extra
stim pack because - so how many how many
students I have four now you can get a
massive knife okay cuz I'm running with
three it's alright I'm gonna have to go
back and I have to go through at all
yeah yeah
but yeah I I ended up doing it was
actually pretty weird how I ended up
doing it with that with the two bosses
I actually I focused on the spider and
every time the spider ended up throwing
out its webs I targeted the other guy I
slowed him and then I like you darted
over to the other to the spider I did a
couple of moves and then I just jumped
back and I kind of just was kiting him
around the room and I did that and
that's why I probably took me so long I
didn't know about the blocking to do the
insta kill but like I ended up doing
that's how I ended up doing it I kind of
kept going and going and going and
that's weird
after the Institute yeah yeah it's very
nice well so how so did you have
problems with that salty so I have to
give you my background I'm a huge Dark
Souls fan yeah so I'm used to the
punishment if that makes sense
yeah I feel like this game is it's
difficult but there's yeah it's it's a
light version trust me because there's
something there sometimes and I play
dashing I played blood-borne all the
Dark Souls the only game really that I
haven't played is Demon Souls and I plan
on playing that because I know for a
fact that Blue Point games is making a
remake for the PlayStation 5 so that's
still on the list but I play - and beat
that like game any game that's like a
Dark Souls game I'll try it even the
surge that was wonky and crappy I beat
that so that just tells you where I'm at
with these games you know I just I enjoy
the challenge like no matter how hard a
boss is like secure oh I don't know how
many times I died - the last boss that
that boss fight trust me
is one of them like the hardest boss
fights I've ever done because there's
like four stages or three or four but it
is ball crushing Lee Harvey is so hard
like that I I was at it for days and I
felt like I was just like man this might
be the first game I don't finish because
I it's just crazy but I ended up being
in this is crazy it's good that last I'm
not gonna spoil it for you guys but the
last boss fight is very very good um
good good I'm surprised I'm surprised
that recent like I said I think it's
fantastic and you guys got to give
respawn so much props for making a melee
combat game like this where they have no
previous works and to knock it out the
browser this game is so smooth from a
combat standpoint it actually boggles my
mind I thought - two questions number
ones a statement wants a question I
agree I think responded I wish I hope
that they end up able you into getting
more Star Wars IPS and you know just the
ends up asking them to produce more and
that would be fantastic what difficulty
were you playing it on uh I have to go
check I think was master right that's
the not the hardest yeah I was
definitely not playing on the hardest
well I will because because what I do
with these games especially that have
difficulties like this I like to play
and then run through it and then put it
up on a harder difficulty but if you put
it on the max to begin with then I don't
have an ability to go back and play it
like yeah especially with the game like
this I want to go start fresh no one
where all the pickups are and stuff and
just go experience the game on a harder
difficulty you know so I'll I'll be
playing through it again excellent now
you know you you enjoy playing those
types of those games it seems like the
the dark soulless games like what's
what's your what's your Jon rough choice
which do you like to play like the story
driven games do you like to play which
which ones like yeah
man my my game choice my favorite type
of game is kind of evolved cuz it feels
like the older I get it's changing
because when I got into gaming and just
kind of got hardcore into it I was big
into multiplayer like Cod and stuff like
that I played black you know black ops
Cod big mainly a big Cod player with my
friends and we'd always get on stuff but
it was a lot easier to do that before I
had kids and a wife and all this other
stuff so I feel like I'm changing my
desires my likes you know saying like I
feel like I'm job I don't know I feel
like I enjoy the single-player
experience a lot more than I did because
it's easier to do that like if it's late
at night I don't have to worry about
getting my buddies on to go play some
some games and stuff and I'm enjoying
the narratives of these single-player
games and especially you like streaming
now I just like interacting with the
chat more when you're going through a
story so that's changed my perspective
but if I had to say what genre I enjoy
the most it's got to be the souls souls
born genre like I I eat eat sleep and
breathe
stuff like if it any of those games I'll
play and beat them you know so yeah it's
it's that's like me i i've never played
the dark souls type series before i've
never played any dark souls ever played
ever played any of those the closest
thing is Star Wars for me I did play a
little bit of action prior to us having
the developer run on and that it gave me
a lot of frustrations because it's not
it's definitely not my genre of game to
play but now that I've been playing Star
Wars it might be something that I might
go back in and take a look into into
playing some more of so yes so do you do
you end up playing like couch co-op
games with your family at all Jude's
anybody else play funny thing is is so
my wife barely plays she plays like it
depends on the games like she hello
neighbor
I think is the game she played what was
that farm game I don't know she she
picks and choose which game she likes
but my my daughter she's six years old
almost seven she's ever since she was
like super young she's just had the she
wanted to play video games so she's been
playing all kinds of stuff like slam
rancher she's beginning to roblox now
she's played some fortnight she's a
she's a definitely a gamer like if I
buddy that's fall on my path it's my
daughter so she's she's been to that so
he will play together and then we have a
switch so we'll play those games
we're to be getting Luigi's Mansion for
her for Halloween I mean Halloween for
Christmas it's a it's a Halloween game
yeah we'll play that together and stuff
like that the switch is really good for
like family type games and stuff like
playing together yeah I I want to pick
up something for my niece it was I can I
can tell that she's got that that little
gamer in her and my my parents are
her parents are trying to hold her back
so I'm gonna yeah yeah I'm gonna try to
do something I know it's faster yeah
foster that yeah that desire yeah every
time every time she comes over I'm like
hey Emma I want you to play this game
and tell me your opinion I put her in my
computer chair and I'm like this is what
you have to do and she's like okay and
then she'll end up playing and like guy
I know that there's a game called I
think it's nano typer where you have to
type words to kill creatures and stuff
so I was like here you go I'm like Emma
you gotta type those words she's like
okay it should type them to do and it's
so adorable and we're gonna work that's
so well is so cool so yeah I'm gonna
definitely have to do something for her
there yeah the funny thing about gamers
and any kind of like you pick up things
you like it's not something that you
could just like force upon people or
even change cuz like my dad had this
weird excuse for not having a gaming
system in the house you said it would
like record TV so I ended up having to
like get my own stuff my dad's not even
into sports and I love sports my dad
could care less about video games so
it's not like a for-sure thing that your
kids are gonna love video games or
anything that you like so the fact that
my my daughter just gravitated towards
that was like crazy for me you know
that's good that's real good yeah I just
something something just popped in my
head and I wanted to ask you before
about your podcast yep when you do your
podcast you do something kind of very
unique it's from yeah
well I've seen that is all of the
pop-ups so when did you start doing your
pop-ups while you were doing your
podcast and and why did you why did you
decide to do those and like why did you
decide those specific memes because
those in pop ups because they know that
the same ones that you use over and over
night yeah yeah I so it's I try to add
to those but it's like a time issue I
guess it's part of a lazy issue too but
yeah ever since I got OBS I've been
wanting to do different things with the
stream you know eventually maybe we'll
put gameplay in there I just wanted to
do something different and I I I
gravitate towards
and comedy and not taking things too
seriously because a lot of people just
take it to you know gaming and all this
other stuff just to seriously like
life's too short to not laugh and stuff
so a lot of times I'll be putting memes
up there or gifts that don't even make
sense and they're just funny to me so
I'll pop it up there someone says
something and I'll try to put a reaction
to it it's just it kind of just cuts the
the time for people cuz like I'd like to
see the reaction from the chat I'll be
like oh [ __ ] look you see that was funny
hear that like wow what was that you
know saying it's just it's just I don't
know it's different for me I like I
found a little I found it funny when we
were yeah when we were on the podcast
and you were putting pictures of kijima
up and stuff cuz that about like I like
I'm just sitting there shaking my head
throughout the whole entire conversation
and I was just yeah like I I will admit
I tried to jump in once to try to defuse
the situation and then I just got
knocked down real quick I was just like
I'm done I'm walking away but it was a
fantastic conversation now yeah now who
on the podcast would you say is a
recurring person and where did you end
up finding them so like panel members
yeah your panel members
alright so Centurion where did I find
him he was doing txr I believe if I I
just you know watch that and I liked his
takes and stuff like that so then we got
him on and then I asked him to be a
panel member and then big cloud I think
I saw him on booms Channel and then I
watched his stuff and then same things
there had them on it's about you know
clicking with the other people it's kind
of like a family thing or whatever just
kind of have that energy on the stream
it's tough - we kind of went through an
influx of change all at once but doing
this for so long for like years two
years people have personal life's they
go in and out sometimes they can do it
sometimes they got to learn that's all
understandable and then sometimes you'll
be lighter on panel members or sometimes
you'll go heavy but then you try to fill
with guests but yeah that's usually how
it works out you just get people to
guest and if
a click then you know get him on yeah I
well I mean you look out saying before
you and I like yep we who we were back
and forth for about a month with me
Germanic come on and it was it just it
was horrible and I was like I finally
I'm I guess I could be on the channel
and then you messaged me like we have
too many panel members um and I was just
like I'm like I've cancelled enough on
you I'm fine I'll be there next week and
I'm actually worried and I said to be
that way and and I I had to I had a lot
of fun doing that and it was great yes
it was definite so it's just those other
people it's just those two people yeah
for right now it's just us three yeah
trying to get like two guests a week
until I figure out you know I think four
panel members is good I mean including
myself because if you get too many
people on there plus guests it just kind
of people don't have enough time to talk
yeah like you have like a two hour
podcast and yes that's approximately
what you do and like I know like the
guys they go between 2 hours to 3 hours
I'm just like that is a really long time
to sit there and talk I mean when we
were kind of discussing this and we were
like well how are we gonna do this how
long do you think
and I was like an hour-ish over a little
kind of so because like I want to talk
to you I want to get information out of
you and we want to talk to you about
stuff and like we don't want to be like
you know feeling like this is us
drilling you with questions and talking
no no no no here's the deal
I love podcasting like if I could do it
schedule-wise I could do it every day if
I like boom stars yeah yeah yeah like I
could literally I could talk for if I
needed to if the saltiest gaming podcast
had no panel members no guest I feel
like I could talk for two hours
pretty pretty easily you know so it's
just one of those things where I like
gaming and I could talk about it as much
as I need to or whatever it's not a
force thing and you know it's I just
like doing it that's what I do you know
yeah it's fantastic it's fantastic
MJ did you did you happen to have any
questions you're good
you okay here you read the red bowline
you good he's been getting destroyed
with his finals and stuff so ah
Elwood but you do you have any questions
you can think of what would you say to
people about like stayin genuine you
know there's so many people like yeah
just constantly flip-flop you know yeah
yep you know all right so this is big
for me cuz I don't know lots of people
will say what they want to say about you
and I've just I've learned that on
social media there's a lot of people to
just want to hate if just to hate or
whatever I know for a fact that I don't
get as many views as I could get if I
was putting on a stick or pandering to
one audience or another because plain
and simple a lot of times in YouTube
if you want to get the views then you
have to pander to an audience it's like
in gaming you have PlayStation hardcore
people or Xbox hardcore people they want
to hear everything that they want to
hear right they want to hear the
positives about their platform and they
want to hear the negatives about the
other platform and then if you deviate
outside of that you'll get people
calling you a pony one day or calling
you an X pot the next day and that
actually happened on my channel today
you know I did it a an Xbox video I said
everything just like I've always done on
my channel I I just give my opinions and
I just tell it how I feel it's my
opinion
I'm not flip-flopping for views or any
of that it's just going with the flow
you know if I have something negative to
say about Xbox I'll say it if I have
something negative to say about
PlayStation or Nintendo or whatever or
something positive I'll say that and a
lot of times the polar opposite ends of
the spectrum
they don't like that so the unsub from
you block you unfollow you call you a
flip-flopper say you're doing it for
fuse whatever because they don't get it
they're not used to hearing that because
they get these corporate shills that
tell them everything that they want to
hear it's kind of like politicians if
you get with a certain group they tell
you everything that you want to hear not
necessarily what you need to hear so
yeah it ruffles some feathers but yeah
staying true to yourself that's more
important to me in the long run because
I couldn't put on a stick or you know
pander to a certain audience and be
happy about what I'm doing you know so
for the good of the bad I understand
it's not for everybody but uh I think
it's important for the in the long run
if you want to continue to do it because
if you're not being true to yourself
you're not gonna want to keep doing this
stuff trust me you know so yeah I think
the biggest problem right now is they
everybody sees it as a get rich quick
type of thing which yeah yep you know I
mean the reason why I started doing
playstation content is because I play
the games and trust me like the
experiences that I'm having on that
platform is got a war for example is the
best my favorite game of all time and
playing it simple I played blood-borne I
beat it all these things you can see on
my channel like the things that I'm
saying like I posted something about
splatoon I'm on my Twitter I play games
cuz I'm gonna gamma gamer and no matter
how many times you try to tell people
that they they still formulate their own
opinions like if if a games on a toaster
and I like it and it plays good I'll
play it you know so I'm not locked down
on one platform or represent one brand I
just you know it is what it is so I did
start I did start off as an Xbox channel
because that's all I had you know and
then I got a switch and then I got a
Playstation and you know things change
people change but there's lots of people
out there in the community on Twitter
that are fake
and in YouTube they do it for views and
that that's just not what I'm doing
you know so it's just not not me it's
it's kind of funny that you know you are
a very genuine individual and it makes
me laugh because your your Twitter
handle is salty saltiest gaming yeah
which is what you think would make you
want to ruffle people's feathers but at
the same time you're not it's you're
just you're even keeled always yeah well
here's the here's the deal like I
understand a chiral thing like if you're
if you're a genuine person trust me
people are not going to like you
they won't people like to hear fake
things trust me they want to hear what
they want to hear like I said I can't I
can't beat this drum enough people will
tell you everything if someone tells you
everything that you want to hear 100% of
the time they're fake trust me because
you're gonna you need criticism in your
life right you need to hear something
like - in order to grow as a person or
an individual you need to hear some of
that stuff that you want don't want to
hear you know so that's that's just my
personal take on it but like I said I
know myself as a person it ruffles
people's feathers I get it not everybody
likes everybody and that's cool man
that's it's understandable you know so
right L did you have any more that you
were thinking of yeah I actually started
to actually have a look at notepad right
here and I actually write notes now cuz
I when we have guests because I know
that I'm gonna forget if I don't ask I
actually had one one question before
before a final question what's your
channel it almost has like a boom yeah
that that happened like overnight what
what do you think can can what do you
think helped you to do that that little
that little boom that you had because if
because if you look at like your old
content like back in the day you know
you had you had pretty standard numbers
and now you have
over the standard numbers what do you
think an can contest to that all right
so I was actually thinking about making
videos on this so I'm so stoked that
we're doing this interview honestly
because it lets me talk about the [ __ ]
that I've been wanting to talk about to
people because I know people ask these
questions yeah about growing everything
I've watched a ridiculous amount of
videos on everything YouTube like you're
talking about algorithm there's so much
that goes into it man yeah and I still
don't think that I understand what's
going on to be honest with you guys you
know like I'll put it up you could look
at your analytics in half the time I'm
questioning you know it's this robot in
the sky like I'm putting my content and
I'm putting my work in and I feel like a
video that I put a hundred percent
effort into which I do and I feel like
it's gonna be great it just tanks in my
opinion it takes right and then I get
depressed about that are I feel bad
about it and then another time you put
out of the video that you didn't even
think that you're gonna put out and then
it just it explodes right I don't know
like it's hard work it's not like it's
making videos when you feel like you're
down on making videos you know like
there's been times where I've been
wanting to stop doing content because I
feel like I'm not getting the views that
I feel like I need to get but it's just
perseverance man honestly and it's
making my content better in not saying
hey I'm I'm fine with what I'm doing
it's like I want to do better I want to
make my audio better right so I got what
did I get I got different programs right
I got audacity which is an audio editing
program so I'll record takes and I'll
take the UM zout or the likes or the
breathing that's small little things but
trust me it goes a long way with videos
and then with I went from 720p to 1080p
videos for gameplay that's a small thing
but I think it's bigger right and then
my thumbnails try to get them better
trying to optimize my titles trying to
learn the algorithms and the changes
that
that's everything I'm trying to make my
videos longer and better quality all
that stuff I think helps yeah but like I
said it's like flipping a coin up when
you post these videos cuz trust me
there's times where my videos tank and
I'm just like wow dude like what what
did I what did I do wrong right but
sometimes it's not it's most the time
it's not your fault trust me
YouTube just a strange you to be game
you know exactly exactly so yeah that's
that's the degree answer to that you
know it's it's a collaboration of a
bunch of different things that just help
you push you forward and that's what
that's what everyone really needs to do
they really need to see what they like
you know where they're lacking and then
just push forward and be better like
there's there's no reason to be
complacent on where you are you can
always make yourself better yeah don't
don't be complacent in your content yes
is it's exactly what it is exactly so uh
you're gonna answer that question that
barbecue sauce asked you okay yeah yes
some more I never heard that before but
uh really really I I know what ASMR is
but I don't know why I would do it I
have a good quality mic now I mean but I
don't know why I don't know why anyone
would would do it either
isn't that where they're like rubbing on
their mic and like well they're not I
guess some low or like yeah it's an
audio stimulation my brother said you
read a creepy creepy article that
someone said that they listened to a
specific streamer that did ASMR and it
was the best night's sleep they ever got
and I'm like that that's cool man creepy
a little bit then III I've listened to
those streams if you have if you get a
good headset it's it's it's unique
experience but my daughter is already
into that
because listening to like people squish
slime things you hear that it's like oh
satisfying what do you know that's weird
that is very weird so salty I'm gonna
ask you our our final question if you
will if you could live in one video game
and for fantasy environment what would
it be
meaning Star Wars Harry Potter it could
be a book could be a movie it could be
an anime any of that stuff you know my
answer dude
III know your answer but I have to I
have two hours maybe
starwars hours give me a lightsaber and
get out of my way I will chop you in
half
give me those force powers let me live
in that yeah it's phat fantastic it's a
it's a great it's a great world I love
that place yeah yeah and they have it in
Florida and in California do I need to
make my way over there dude
no you live closer to which I'm in
Arizona so we're about six hours from LA
so honestly it would be easy to get over
there but it's a money thing and it's
like I have kids I bring in whoever I
can on the military discount this is
crazy yo my my friend shameless is his
sister was working there and he got in
for free so is him and his wife were
going like every weekend I was like holy
[ __ ] yeah people who work for CBS no
matter what you do like there was a my
sister knows a girl who like does the
tapes and crap you know like almost like
rewinding tape and stuff you know for
CBS and she has a card that allows her
to get into you know Disneyland just to
bring like five people with every time
what yeah purt purt to working for them
so you doesn't matter where you work as
long as you work for Disney conglomerate
one of those virtual jobs yes yes I will
be a customer service representative for
my home I don't mind so well fantastic
well I had a fantastic time I hope you
did too salty why don't you tell
everyone your you know your plugs were
where we can find you your dates your
times were you know all that fun stuff
so first place is Twitter saltiest
gaming the eyes of one hopefully that we
change and quick shortly might be
getting the actual name without the one
hopefully shortly what else twitch
trying to push that a lot twitch.tv
slash salties gaming and then YouTube
salties gaming two words salty gaming
podcast every a every Thursday at 8 p.m.
Eastern so that's it it's a fantastic
rate and and I like I was saying before
I was actually on the podcast with the
guys last week two weeks ago two weeks
ago last week was Thanksgiving and I had
a blast it's a lot of fun great content
great conversation if you guys have time
on Thursday nights go over there check
them out there they're great they're
good sir yes they are go check them out
send your MJ in find me on Twitch at
MJ's a box and you your accent yes when
will you come back as soon as you go
back home for for winter recess yeah
probably
that's great let's figure three weeks
for me yep I think three or four yeah
make sure I'm gonna make sure I get you
back on on Twitter for the Christmas
time Oh boogie yourself you can find me
Oh buddy Oh 208 on Twitter and a mixer
and even on YouTube even though I don't
post there okay oh and I'm there on
mixer weekdays Tuesday through Friday
around 6:30 7:00 p.m. depending on if
kids get their homework then get your
homework done kids soon no I wanna I
want to play video games basically yes
yes well I'm happy that you were you're
able to get back on your schedule I'm
happy that you know
the family is back together and
everything as well and myself I am Snell
doe that is s and a ly do I am on Twitch
Monday through Friday 7:00 to 10:00
unless I am here
you sometimes a little later as of late
it's been as of late a little later
iron Lords podcast guys should go check
those guys out on Sundays at 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time there they're
doing some great work there please check
out bunch of gaming dotnet we have a lot
of amazing content there check out
old-school style he is he is out right
now check him out on on Twitter old
school talk talk he's guys YouTube
channel a lot of tech stuff going on we
hear our roundtable with the stream team
we're here live Mondays on the YouTube
channel with under the islands podcast
with these guys we go with our podcast
on multiple different platforms on
Wednesday mornings when you guys wake up
so go ahead and follow us on table
stream on Twitter oh we will give you
posted notifications of who our guests
are when things are going on and things
like that
next week is we're going to be having
someone on on Tuesday we have anchor man
who's on Tuesdays he he wants to be sure
we got him in this year and I he was it
was the only day to do it so we kind of
what kind of dude did that so please
check us out next week so yeah I think
and if you have any questions for anyone
please email us at roundtables stream
team at gmail.com we have that email
available for everyone and greatly
appreciated thank you very much for
hanging out salty thank you for you know
driving some knowledge on us to greatly
appreciate it you're awesome hey no
problem
sound thank you very much and remember
everyone to dream big and keep gaming
and we will see you next week everybody